[Music]
was that
time just ticking away yeah it felt like
it it felt like you know when you get a
five four three it feels like there
should be a blast off
well imagine if you had like a condition
in your life that kept giving you a
countdown from ten just for no reason
you like some sort of you know brain
anomaly that keeps counting down from
ten
you'd be so nervous you know you spend
your entire life just on tender hooks
like when that five happened just then
i was terrified for a moment it's like
um
remember you guys did that and lost
you just had a thing ticking down
for like
i can't remember how far off
the ticker was do you was it days or
months or
what the take down no it was only like
it was a four but for 45 minutes wasn't
it
was it i think it was a 45 minute second
if you put the numbers in it resets it
yeah but you don't know what for
like you were saying just like if you
had a tick down in your life and you
don't know what's going to happen you
don't know if your head's going to
explode or like the picture's going to
fall off the wall or
you know
i don't know you go here you go another
universe
a parallel one
and and do you remember what it actually
was for in the end like did it open a
bunch of doors that we couldn't get into
or did it like did we all get like a
cuddly toy or something with the clock
loss never actually answered all my
questions if i'm honest though
not sure how many questions are answered
in any way to be fair
there was though
i think as i remember it
it was
a cog system
where
where the island would the island would
move slightly and
using a cog system
so say say for instance the island was
in a rolex watch
this
wasn't it was it
no no no
he told me if it told me that i'd i'd
have liked that don't like that but it
didn't tell me that
okay all the cogs moved at one point
right
and when but
get some clarification
when the cogs moved
did did that movement like pick up polar
bears
and then monsters
and then they got trapped because they
were on like a the pogba is on a piece
of ice and as the cog moves it it goes
over the piece of us and picks up the
polar bear and then it wants to get back
on its eyes but now it's on the cog
and
so
now dom you're getting somewhere yeah so
the cog system is actually
has went off a few times before you guys
arrived is that what you're saying yeah
so that's how
the polar bear
and maybe the trees are all shaking
because it's on a dodgy
cloud
right
and then there's a there's a monster
made of smoke wasn't too sure what that
was about and then
at one point there was a massive statue
that only had four toes
wondering if maybe one of the one of the
cogs just shaved off one of the toes
so easily
there's a lot of accidents in in
machinery like that that's true didn't
you know someone who
severed their arms in a paper cutting
machine
so here's the thing tom i don't know if
you know this but i used to be a book
binder i've heard this before i was an
actor
i used to make books
and uh i worked in the print finishing
department
of uh a princess
just can i interject
yeah
print finishing so that someone prints
something but it's not that great and
then you finish it off is that what no
no
so the printed page
whatever it is
comes to us as a printed page but that's
it so if it's a book
it'll maybe have page one
nineteen
twenty eight
sixty three a hundred
dollars
no you're okay for the you're okay for
the time being right
so um
so depending how that page gets folded
it then makes
part of the book
so i in the print finishing do you fold
that paper not manually a machine does
it
yeah then maybe you're on the machine
that puts all the pages together
then you're on the machine that cuts all
the edges off then you're on the machine
that sticks the cover on there's a lot
that goes into making a boot on yeah
yeah
but to get back to your point about did
i know anybody get injured if you go
to madame tussauds
in london
now there is a whole sec
i think now
yeah certainly the last time i went
certainly the last time i went there's a
whole department
on
injuries and disfigurements from the
print finishing department of printers
oh
because of all the things that can
happen to you
right and that does that that has
something to do with cogs is that what
you're saying
and around the boat way
so
the island
the island of lost
was a print finishing department
in a big printers that we call the world
it's it's fun doing the podcast with you
but i feel like
i
tend to follow it a lot more when we're
in person when we're doing it
via computer terminals i get confused
you know it's confusing this
this is the first time we've done this
dom and it's because you've you've went
off haven't you you went off for a
little bit you went traveling
when traveling you're not in los angeles
no i'm working but um i'm working in
europe in ireland as as they say in the
united states ireland they put a little
r in there
ireland probably because
irish people have an r i don't know but
i love ireland
i don't think we're allowed to see what
you're doing there
well but we can say
that you're flexing your uh acting
muscle
yeah i mean i've already it's already um
gone out while i'm why i'm in ireland in
terms of like you know if if if anyone
reads about what what projects are being
made it did go out on deadline i'm
making a show called moonhaven
um which is based on the moon
um so i think oh it's a fictional moon
it's not the moon that we know because
obviously uh
there's a lot of stuff with gravity and
uh the atmosphere
uh that are very different from
how we would navigate around on the moon
um but they're using some of these like
bleaker
more isolated more unspoiled
natural areas to represent
a type of moon you know
i like that tom because you know that if
you had to ask me it'd be my favorite
genre
i know i normally you know i normally
ignore your work because it's not a
genre that i'd be watching
that's not true
i watch everything
of course but um but i'm very excited
about this one you're on the moon
i'm on the moon
um
i think the films you've grown a
moustache on the moon
well yeah but i also think my
because of the way that my beard is
greying
it now starts to look like i have more
of a moustache because this is now
becoming
obsolete yeah that's great yeah
so that exactly that happens to me for
people who are just listening
uh tom has got an amazing what looks
like a moustache that goes all the way
around from his nose up to his sideburns
but it's only because there's a bit of
gray right here on his chin
that makes it almost invisible
which is exactly how i look in my past
passport um i've got that same look it
looks like a huge mustache yeah
i would like to shave my face but
unfortunately for this project i can't
but i did think it was really
interesting that the project that i did
before this pre-covered
uh a couple of years ago now in borneo
i had to
grow
essentially an old handlebar moustache
with a beard and now it's become my real
life so
what's that about life imitates that you
know i mean also we should point out
it's way easier for people watching the
show than it is for people listening to
the show but you and i
got the same memo and are wearing the
same
clothing today
tom and i have to say for people who are
not watching this show you should be
because we are wearing some of the
greatest
clothing available to humanity
um i am wearing the most comfortable
hoodie
and uh and a hat
that will not only uh
defend your eyes from the sun
but will also show other human beings
how
fashionable and and pretty you are
yeah
also in california shields your head
from uh any any acid rain
exactly
but we are wearing official
the friendship onion merch
now it's not it's taken us quite a while
to get this people have been asking they
say i'd love to clothe myself in some
friendship onion so we listen look at
john you look fantastic john look at
that onion just place there on your
chest
i have an onion it's well i have the
words the friendship onion here on my
forehead
look at that stitching all the quality
my goodness
it was hand stitched on by grandmothers
in ireland
and it also fits perfectly on your dog's
head because you sent me a photo of that
earlier on in the week
didn't he look fantastic my dog was just
around there i'm sure he'll show up
later in the episode he's an absolute
cracker and he looks fantastic and it's
not only hoodies
yeah there's t-shirts
hang on i was going to wear this one i
was going to wear this dom but it's a
ladies you see and it wouldn't fit over
my
massive chest yeah your big mac look at
the onion
oh i like that detail
so that's
the front friendship onion on the back
is that right
there's never too much onion storm look
at that it's lovely that isn't it gonna
get some of that anyway i'm done
pitching that for a minute so i'm going
to remove my sweater because i'm quite
hot
then that's a good game
now please be my guest um maybe you can
get your wonderful wife to put on that
ladies t-shirt and model it for us one
day
yeah well i'll ask her i don't know if
she'll do it but she might do i don't
know i can always ask them
right you keep everybody entertained
while i remove my hat and sweater
right while you do that i'll tell
everyone out there if they're interested
where they can get hold of wonderful
friendship onion clobber
that you can put in your stockings for
christmas
you can get it from
friendshiponionpodcast.com
we have chosen not to include a v
at the start of that
uh web page it's just
friendship onion
podcast dot com someone some cheeky
chappie or chappet
took
the v
and made it their own so drop
the th e it's just the shortcut
spreadship on your podcast.com
friendship on your podcast
maybe the person who stole the
friendship onion podcast
uh maybe they're listening to the
friendship onion podcast and we would
like to offer you
no cash for that we will certainly not
be giving you cash but we will give you
a t-shirt
a sweater
and a hat do you think them
i think is that too much and okay no
that's fine it's a negotiation we're in
a negotiation i'm i think i'm gonna
raise the stakes on the negotiation
a t-shirt
a hoodie right a hat right and if the
person is interested
we'll have them on as a guest on the
show to ask him about why they chose
that
friendship on your podcast
i'd like to ask them that's right
so if you are the person who took the
friendship onion podcast as uh would you
call that a name what is that a domain a
domain a domain yes
if you took the domain the friendship
onion podcast then please get in touch
you'll get a t-shirt
a hat
a sweater and if you want you can appear
on the show and explain to us
why you go around taking names of of
shows i i think it'd be an interesting
conversation i wonder what else we've
got
i think it will too yeah i mean
that would be a good living you could
just sit all day and say what's it what
shows are coming out
and then just get ones that are kind of
maybe about to run out really good ones
like dracula.com bet you could sell that
for a lot
well i think i might not be right here
but i thought that's why
20th century fox changed their name to
fox searchlight is because somebody
bought 21st century fox
and they refused to pay for it i think
but you've got to pay for it because
that's the whole idea otherwise you've
just got it and what you're going to do
with it
do you remember when we did the guy
who's got the friendship onion podcast
what's he going to do
i don't know i don't know
um but maybe he'll tell us when he comes
on yeah he can he can make a name for
himself if he comes on our part or she
and comes in our pockets and explains
himself but do you remember when we
first got to well not first got to new
zealand but very very early in our new
zealand
um
rehearsal process
i believe it was mark odesky or it might
have been ian mckellen but
i'm not sure how i'm confusing those two
but one of the two of them said to us
you should buy
your name as a domain you should buy
billyboyd.com you should buy
dominicmonahan.com
and i didn't really bother and someone
definitely does have dominicmonahan.com
yeah somebody took billy boyd as well
because i did have a website for a while
and it was billyboy.net because that's
all i could get right i think i just
calm
how's the weather in in dublin
do you know it's been absolutely
wonderful um i mean it's the first of
october today and we have had probably
one day
of
slightly showery wet weather and apart
from that it's been crisp and cold and
sunny
and beautiful um so have you bothered uh
have you bothered buying an umbrella i
would i would ask you
you put an extra syllable in there an
umberella
yeah is that no
umbrella that's right
yeah i just got umbrella umbrella isn't
it spelt with an a in there though um
something is umbrella
i
not only in america but also in the uk
john is it spelt umbrella or um
i honestly have never even heard of this
second option it's always big
really oh no
you're saying somewhere in the world
they say umbrella
uh i think it's um
umbrella
umb
b and then put an a after the b
like the opposite from the alphabet um
i see yeah i've never heard that in my
life it's just like how you say tuna
tuna
or vitamins i notice you you all say
vitamins we say
i think it's just umbrella well now now
you say that bills because i'm very
close to my front door i always have a
pocket-sized umbrella by my front door
because we're in an island an extender
yeah is it good in here i'll show you
i shall return
he's off now
an umbrella is always good in the rain
well here you go
that's about as small as a pocket
umbrella gets with it still being
a decent umbrella above your head
don't don't open up your head up oh god
you opened it above your head indoors
that's unlucky that
isn't it i thought i was walking on your
ladders
no but putting the number ill up indoors
over your head john very quickly google
how you get rid of the bad the bad luck
for that would you please
you'll probably have to turn around
three times spit and say queen victoria
or something i'll do that anytime you
want that's really putting john to work
today
yeah yeah it's good
it's been a while ah anyway i mean we
don't even know what he is
um
since they've been away
you and i haven't really
played that much league of legends have
you have we so this
league of legends update is gonna be
very
very different you've been playing with
new pals you got new friends bills
done i've got lots of new um league of
legends friends because
you're in a different time just now i
mean you're backing forward we know that
and i'll see you in the studio but
at the moment while we're apart i can't
get the times worked out
where we can get on on the rift together
so i have started playing with some
other people and one of them said to me
you know what
you should play nami
he's a support
in the bottom
and dom i love it
she's got she's like uh would you call
that a lady that's half fish half lady
under the ocean remember they made a
movie
a mermaid
and she's got a tidal wave dom
so when everybody's in a big fight
i just go like this ah and i fire a
tidal wave and everybody flies up in the
air and then all my team can kill them
while they're just up in the air
hey tom you know one thing i love about
fall
as the weather gets a little cooler
getting out the back
lighting a nice fire and having your
friends around nice bottle of wine maybe
singing some songs and i tell you who
makes a great fire pit
solo stove you know that because you've
been round mine
having a great time around that fire
they do make a fantastic solo stove and
if you want i can tell you why they make
a fantastic solo stove it's made with
stainless steel
and has a
360 degree airflow
system that's patented that maximizes
efficiency whilst minimizing smoke and
they're also perfectly portable you can
move them around your garden to
different spots and enjoy a different
kind of vibe with your solo still it's
absolutely true dom i love mine i really
do and i got a new thing i got the lid
for it so when it's not a stove i use it
as a table now dom it's great
so get the perfect fire pit for those
full nights and make your backyard a
destination with a spectacular fire pit
from solo stealth
shop the fall event now and get an extra
10 off when you use promo code onion at
checkout
they're so confident you'll love it they
offer a lifetime warranty and a 30-day
free return policy go to
solostove.com and remember you get 10
off when you use the promo code onion
enjoy
hey friends sometimes when billy and i
are collaborating on an idea
we use
miro
miro is a collaborative white boarding
online platform created to help people
visualize discuss and share their work
that's right dom you can write on it
draw use videos sticky notes diagrams
even audio to conceptualize your vision
a lot of people are finding it difficult
just now outside of the traditional
office well miro really helps to
collaborate online miro is creating a
revolution in how we create and
collaborate so join the over 20 million
users today you can sign up and use miro
today for free go to miro that's
m-i-r-o dot com slash onion to start
your free account
sign up today and take advantage of
three free white boards with this
exclusive offer go to miro m-i-r-o dot
com slash onion and start using miro
today there's no reason to delay
does it do to the allied team do they
fly up in the air as well
my team no they're fine they just ride
through it
lovely and she's got a brilliant heel so
she can heal my team as well really good
or herself
she's got a bubble she can throw a
bubble at somebody and if the bubble
goes in them it lifts them up in the up
in the air as well and say i was playing
with you i can put three bubbles on you
and your next three hits at anyone will
slow them down and give them more damage
as well
oh no i was so much there i made myself
thirsty dumb i'll just have a drink
water bottle
oh look at that oh wow
the quality
billy is putting up a wonderful drinking
vessel
available at friendshiponionpodcast.com
not the friendship onion podcast
friendship onion podcast.com
i'll tell you what tom water has never
tasted so good and it looked dumb
it comes with a carabiner that's free
that that comes with it
amazing incredible you can stick that on
your bag you can stick it on the end of
your umbrella you can put that whatever
you want and that will just hang there
for whenever you feel like you might be
dehydrated or just need a little
pick-me-up yeah that's wonderful another
thing you can do tom when you're on set
if you're feeling a bit under pressure
one day you can fill that up with vodka
slip away no one will ever know it's on
yeah great that's a that's a great
little tip i love that
um
just going back to league of legends for
a second
does does nami have a trident i tried
yes she does
that's where the three bubbles come from
i suppose and she'll she'll point that
at people but to be honest you know that
what's your normal hit called what's
that called again you like your basement
your basic attack your basic attack is
she doesn't do much damage with that to
be honest okay
all right but well i i really like her i
think
and dom
dom
you'll be very proud of me here i got my
first s plus
yeah i love that that's brilliant
i can't wait to see i got an s minus
and then the next day again s plus
anyone who doesn't play league of
legends that's the best score that you
can get and i had i've never got
anything past a c
for about three months
and all of a sudden because of nami
i'm on an s plus done
very proud of you bills um and you're
right it has been tough with time zones
because basically when i'm kind of
shutting it down at the end of the night
and just trying to
lower my stimulus is when you're waking
up in the morning and vice versa so
we've struggled but maybe after this
podcast maybe we can fit in a quick game
you never know
maybe we could um text elijah
in fact why don't i text elijah right
now and say
we are going on to play league of
legends and see if i get anything back
before the end of the show
okay we can do it are you thinking about
elijah
coming onto league of legends as
a fruit where do you see it now tom
honestly
i've
i've given up which is a terrible thing
to admit but it's it's true
you can you can lead a horse to water
but you can't make it play league of
legends
i
asked
and elijah said yes and then he did the
tutorial and then he got to level three
that was the last time i saw him so he's
not even opened up all of his summoner
spells yet and he can't play
draft
and he doesn't have
smite
and
he's not he's not played for probably a
month just when i arrived in dublin he
was like yeah i'll play i'll play
and then he's never played with me once
and to be honest
i've given up so i think
i'm going to say strawberry seed is the
smallest
i'm going to say
an orange seed
what
he's got back straight away dumb i just
what do you say
i'm i'm not going to vote yet i'm not
going seeds or or fruits
i've said
means i'm a plain league of legends in a
couple hours a u.n he says
oh [__]
with an exclamation mark and i've got
three dots i've got three darts tom
hold on
now we know he listens
we yeah why not i'll shall i try sean um
we know we know he listens to the
podcast and we know that he feels guilty
the more we mentioned that he's not
played with us so maybe this is the kick
up the arse he needs i'll text sean
right now
you do sean
okay hang on league of legends
this could be a huge wonder uh
what's he saying
he says ah a g h exclamation mark it's
not good in anyone's not good
he says
i can't today
and then i won't tell you all the things
that he's doing about that he says
he says i'll spend in the whole day
running errands
okay and then he says
oh
wait wait don't you're not gonna like
this oh god
he's uh dumb oh god
give me give me a few weeks and i'm in
weeks
it says weeks
what does he need weeks for
he's he's running errands
wow that's a big list in it
imagine how many errands takes weeks wow
he is a larger one
to learn from you
he might
if it's weeks it might take him that
long to get those massive
contact lenses out of his eyes because
they're so big
it might be a week and a half on his
right eye and then we can hop on his
left then he cleans him then he puts him
back in then he can play league of
legends with us
could be that dumb i've got it i've got
to drop it down to
i mean i'll think i was a plum how was
that plumped on we were at a plum i
can't he can't be our plum though
well he's growing seed for me
these are raising a reason for me
well let's move on because it's it's
like someone's it's like someone's
opened up a bag in the kitchen and let
off a bad smell i'm above trying to
ignore it both of our friends
uh refusing to play league of legends
with us and one of them said i'll play
with you in less than a month great
all right hey we've had some questions
i mean
if you if you were um if you were trying
to woo a young lady
if you were trying to wear a young lady
and she said to you i'm running some
errands today but you know
maybe we could hang out in a couple of
weeks
that's probably it
a few weeks
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails
anyway moving on
shall i read the first question now and
we'll see where this takes us
this question
this question comes from julie s
in huntsville texas
and she says dom and billy
were you aware of the lord of the rings
musical that started in 2008 my friend
jessica and i have been listening to the
soundtrack and we actually quite enjoy
it
if you were aware of it what are your
thoughts this is a lot of questions here
by the way from julius would you ever
consider playing in a musical where you
have to sing and dance i love your show
more than warm bread and butter so
basically the questions are did we know
about the motherings musical
what do we think have we ever wanted to
be in a musical
well dominic
this would have been a totally different
answer from you five years ago
i know that for a fact
dom was never a fan of musicals and then
something happened and i'm not even sure
what it was it could have been the
miserab was it
are you eating a gummy bear well talking
sorry sorry about it absolutely
delicious satiating myself but go on
um
myself i've always been a fan of
musicals i love them i like the more
sort of modern ones probably the best
you know like um
rent and and hamilton now and things
like that but i like all musicals and i
like i like the old german this sort of
the thrippingy opera the thrippany opera
that kind of thing you know brilliant
um but yeah i love all musicals and i
did hear about the lord of rings and i
never got to see it which was a real
shame because i think in my mind i just
thought it would run forever i just
thought oh well that will probably
be a huge success
and um i think they had a lot of
problems
as i remember it did they not have a
very
difficult stage set up
that for the first few months wasn't
working well
right now
i was i think spider-man did have its
own problems on the west yeah on
broadway on broadway yeah when you when
you say a difficult stage system with
the lord of the rings show is it a
series of cops
it was all cogs that didn't quite fit
and then so you'd be in lost lorient and
then the cogs would move and it would be
a hell in the shire this is that what it
was in my mind dad never saw it i don't
know yeah but um
for whatever reason it didn't last which
is a real shame i think but i've never
heard the music so i don't know if it's
any good and if a musical doesn't have
great music then that would be the major
fall down so hopefully the music's good
and we we we see it again sometime
and
you know
dom dom can be a an aragorn this thing
you'll yeah
i think like a musical with bad music
it's not really a musical really is it
it's like it's like a
it's like a hot water bottle with cold
water in it it just becomes a bottle
then it's just it's not performing the
function so like a musical with really
bad songs
like that's what you went to go
see and do you know is sing along and
have fun with it so
now i'm not saying that i had bad songs
i don't know that it might be brilliant
i know it didn't last
the cogs
i think
a series of cards
now well i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna answer that question i like
that you answered for me bills and i
would say it was
89 accurate
um
i used to like musicals that's how i got
into acting obviously you know
wisdom was in greece and uh
bugs him alone and oliver twist and all
that kind of stuff then i did go off it
probably in my
mid
to late teens
all the way up until you and i becoming
pals all the way up until you telling me
oh you're missing out you're missing out
on some really great musicals that have
been made and broadway's a great
experience and there's some great things
to see on the west end and i was kind of
like ah
i don't know not really for me type
thing that might have been my own
insecurity because i just thought well i
i don't necessarily think i'm going to
be doing musical theater so maybe i just
kind of you know pushed it away a little
bit
um
and then
i went to see
les miserables in
london on a rainy day when i was killing
time i was kind of you know finished my
work for the day early
walk to the theater to ask if they had
any spare seats they did
i saw it
and thought
like obviously you you were totally
right there's some great
moments as a as an adult watching
musical theater
and then since then i've watched a few
more in fact i'm i'm really looking
forward to the new dear evan hansen film
that comes out
but in terms of wanting to be in a
musical i don't have your beautiful kind
of nightingale lark like voice
i just kind of grunt my songs through
whereas you actually have some finesse
to your voice so i can i can't really
see me being in a musical unless there's
characters in musicals
you know that sing like
ben morrison or
david gray
now william you know
that i am
an absolute snob when it comes to fruit
i will only
put the greatest quality of fruit in my
mouth and then into my garlic because
that's just the type of guy i am you
know i like high quality stuff
we all have uncompromising standards in
other parts of our lives so why skip out
on quality where we spend a third of our
lives and that is in our bed sleeping
the husband and wife team that started
ball and branch realized no sheets on
the market met their standards for
quality so they created their own
super soft and expertly crafted
signature sheets and i tell you tom
i've tried them and i've been sleeping
in them for years and i love them
they're great sheeps ball and branch and
the more you wash them the softer they
get
really great quality and there's no
middleman so it just comes straight to
you from bowling brand so you get that
luxury quality at a fair price to
experience an entirely new standard of
comfort visit ball and branch dot com
get 15 of your first set of sheets with
promo code
onion that's
b-o-l-l
and
branch.com promo code onion
really there is so much going on in the
world right now whether it's stuff
you're excited about like new songs on
spotify or new podcast to listen to
maybe an episode of the friendship onion
perhaps or stuff that you'd rather not
think about maybe you're trying to tune
out some of the hassles of the day maybe
you're trying to concentrate on things
in your life maybe you've got some
studying to do well listen you can't
always control the vibes out there but
you can always control the vibes in your
head with a pair of raycon
wireless earbuds in your ears and i tell
you what i wear a lot of headphones i
wear them for a long time because i'm on
flights and they are extremely
comfy those raycon earbuds are amazing
dawn there's all sorts of ways you can
listen to them they're pure mode balance
mode base mode so you can get it the way
that you want to hear it and they are
super super comfortable there's also a
built-in mic and you can take calls on
your earbuds at just the press of a
button so right now
friendship onion listeners can get 15
off their raikon order at buy
slash raycon.com
that's buy recon dot com slash onion to
save 15
on recons
by raycon.com
i think that's good you know and then
you know like the
like i say the sort of breathtaking or
that you could one of them would be
brilliant
yeah
um do you want to read this
you want to read this next question
you're ready john from kerry m in philly
philadelphia philadelphia buddy
but a cheesecake gold coast
yeah is it
oh
right where you hear this
my brother is part of a group of guys in
philly
who have basement pubs
i like this already dom
we are working
on this oh well we are working on his
but we want it to be lord of the rings
themed it's a fantastic idea the name is
going to be the green dragon well it's a
classic right we even have a sign for
the entrance do you have any ideas of
what we need to include to give it that
green dragon feel we'd love your advice
and we'd love to have something there to
pay homage to you both
homage you trunks
well right off the top of my head i've
not seen this question yet but right off
the top of my head you know how
sometimes
cheeky businesses
will
super glue
a coin onto the floor or onto a
countertop so that people go to grab it
and then they can laugh and kind of go
ah that's great i was just thinking if
you want the green dragon to have a nice
shire like hobbity vibe but also maybe
keep you in kind of a hobbity good humor
and being silly and having fun with your
friends wonder if maybe a few
hobbit shaped
pipes that they smoke
super glued onto the bar top
in a way that might make people reach
out and think oh someone's left a pipe
here but actually the pipe has been
super glued to the countertop i like
that i i like that idea when somebody's
had a couple of eels
and they go to grab it yeah very good
tom and so this is in philadelphia and
they're they've got basement pubs now
are they allowed to sell drink in there
is that just for the friends
is there is that
do you think that once you go
underground level alcohol becomes
a different legality is that right
yeah
if you go below i think it's either 15
or 18 feet
it's basically there is no laws
right
you can do what you want under there
always remember that dom may i suggest
for this pub this green dragon pub if
you're going to sell coffee or tea you
might want
the friendship onion mug
see what you did there
see that um so that if anyone was going
for a coffee say for instance they say i
don't want a drink today i don't want
any beer i don't want any meat i don't
want any whiskey
have a coffee or a tea
from a friendship onion mug and you can
get that at friendship onion
podcast.com
can i ask a question about the mug
hold on uh yes you're in the front with
your hand up yes actually this is a
two-part question first part is
is there anything lit going to have the
second part first oh okay the second
part first which will be in some ways
the first part second part is what's the
color of the interior of that mug and
the first part was is there anything
liquid in there can you show us
right well there is no liquid i was
going to have a cup of tea later so i
had that there
and the inside of it dom is black black
light it's like your heart it says black
black black light
oh that is like a galaxy it's like a
small galaxy inside there
you can stare into that when you
meditate and that will help you find
whatever it is you're looking for that's
another thing you can do with that mug
it looks like
you do it again hang on it looks like a
colonoscopy
brilliant if you just have a look around
the corner there you see
i was just talking about i was just
talking about colonoscopy today have you
guys
mentioned that
nah but i thought i think i should
probably get one well can i can i make a
suggestion
next time you book one
book me in as well we'll get them done
together do you want to do one we'll get
them let's do it in tandem
i'll tell you how i got to colonoscopy
dumb
this morning
because
i all started in the barbers
i went to get a haircut
yeah and i got it down i got it down
quite short there that side's done yeah
i found a little growth here
i found a little thing
and i thought
i'm gonna go and get that seam too
because you shouldn't be you know you
don't get growths and things you
shouldn't i went but anyway
dom you can relax everything's fine they
said oh it's absolutely nothing you
don't need to worry about that they said
we can just leave it he said or we can
uh get rid of it they said i'll just
leave it i was like it's a thing there i
said no get rid of it
is it what how would you describe the
shape
i would see it's like
half a reason
stuck to the side of my head there
now and then i said no i don't want i
don't want to leave that i'm keeping my
i said i'm going to keep my hair quite
short sides now so i'd rather
so they said well we can get rid of it i
said we'll do that and they get
they get liquid nitrogen done right
and and they spray it on it
until it until it gets painful and then
they stop
and then they go hold on we'll do that
again
and then they spray it again tom
a bit for about the same time yeah and
he said give that about a week
that'll scab over fall off don't worry
about it
have you got a plaster on it right now
nothing done nothing let's have a look
let's have a look
oh yeah it looks like you banged your
head
okay yeah bang it on liquid nitrogen
and
do you think you
so i got me thinking i'll just get other
things checked oh you know what i mean
so if you want to call and ask me i'll
i'll book that i'll book that for both
of us
booker's in in tandem but you don't
think it's interesting that earlier on
you described your anguish at elijah not
joining us for a game of league of
legends for at least three weeks as the
size of a raisin and you are now
carrying a raisin-shaped scar
next to your brain
so
i will always have a little piece of
elijah just at my temple
we will
probably mean something
shall i ask another question
yeah i mean why not has it anymore go on
yeah we've got we've got a ton more
actually so we'll try and get through as
many as we can here's a question from
j i'm gonna i'm gonna try as hard as i
can with this name and then maybe you
give a go as well
jessica
jesuski
i would say that was perfect though i i
couldn't improve on that so well done 10
out of 10.
okay location it says
yeah
uh now here's jessica's question hello
friends i have a question that i have
used as a gauge
for all new people i've met for a while
now
you can tell a lot about a person based
on their answer
my question is vos
if you were a kitchen oh hold on
oh god
i was going to say i'll answer as
quickly as i can because i've not read
it and then you know that will be an
honest answer there we go then if you
were a kitchen utensil what kitchen
utensil would you be and why
uh
fish slice is that called a fish slice
the thing this scooper thing that you
would flip things over a spatula thing
because i used that
probably 800 times more than anything
else in the kitchen so i'd like to be
useful so i'd be the the spatula fish
slice thing
lovely that um what were you
my initial answer my instinctual answer
to that would be a straight edged wooden
spoon
because
i like to get in the corners i mean i
like to get in there
get ready and get it all worked out ask
all the questions like with a
colonoscopy
i don't know
um all right jessica great
um yeah good question thank you i don't
know what that tells us about ourselves
but if you'd like to write in and and
let us know jessica what that actually
tells us we will read it out probably
next week probably you you go ahead with
this question it's getting hot in here
i'm gonna take my idea
right okay so nice hoodie is it
comfortable at all very comfy
hey
john what's that you're wearing there in
that beautiful yellow oh it's
interesting that you asked bills
it's a friendship it's actually
that is a good t-shirt i like that
there you are the very onion
the very onion there
nice that i tell you what comfy oh
breathable forget about it breathable
i've never broke breath this much in my
life
i tell you what that is beautiful don
that really suits you that t-shirt
thanks bills
yeah you should wear that around town
you look fine i'll be wearing it for the
rest of the night so you are available
at friendship onion podcast.com anyway
go on bills i digress not the
not me
are we doing another question are we
going to the riddle
oh a riddle yeah let's go to her riddle
you take us to the riddle
well now are you ready
yeah right and the riddle for this week
comes from kristen
that's all i know about her
that's as much information as john is
willing to give us at this point in the
show
these are our crystals
our little voices are very beautiful
and in
but i do
i'm a future friend
who eludes you
you think you can catch me but i'm
always fading
yet i'm still there
in the distance waiting
and then it says thanks at the bottom
but i don't think that's part of the
riddle i think that's maybe just john
saying thanks
yeah
i've not read this before but right
right off the top of my head i think i
know it
dom you i i'm not even going to think
about it and just let you have your
guess and if you blow my mind right here
i'll give you a t-shirt a sweater a hat
and a chance to be on the friendship
onion well this is just my instinctual
knee-jerk answer after you saying it and
me hearing it but is it a shout out
get ready
i think it's cool i'm ready this is a
this is a tricky one it's a tricky one
well that's my answer shadow
a shadow
yeah
that's the wrong answer for the wrong
answer that's not right look i don't
exist but i do
i'm a future friend right
and i thought you think you can catch me
you're always trying to catch a shadow
but i'm always fading like a shadow yeah
i'm still there in the distance like a
shadow waiting oh gosh all right
is it i've got it is it tomorrow is it
tomorrow is it tomorrow john is it
tomorrow
you are correct sir
[Applause]
that was that was fast that was good
i tell you what john i got that one that
was amazing the only thing with the
shadow is a shadow does exist i guess a
shadow does exist it's a good point read
it now knowing what we know now bills
let's tarantino it read it again right
let's see
okay
and what i'd like you to do if you don't
mind so that we get it into your mind
when i finish a line if you could very
quietly say tomorrow so that we we
understand that that's what it is
i don't exist
is that not your mind now i'm sorry sir
but i
me no you're right it's every second
line i don't exist but i do
tomorrow
i'm a future friend who eludes you
you think you can catch me but i'm
always feeding
tomorrow
yes i'm still there i'm in the distance
waiting
tomorrow
and then there's really anxiety thanks
i got that one done i got that and i
think
i'll tell you what that was it was
teamwork
because you said shadow and that made me
think in a sort of
abstract way and then when it when
i'm a future friend for some reason that
just gave me tomorrow but i'd like it to
be put
in writing that it was me that got that
one it was you and if anyone out there
knows where we sit in terms of solving
riddles because i know when we had
michael rosenbaum he solved quite a few
for us but i i think we're i think you
and i are kind of even in this in the
riddle solving stakes i think do you
want some youtube comments
oh yeah yeah let's hear what people are
saying about the show
because here's the exciting thing about
youtube dom and i know that you know
that um i'm slightly obsessed about
getting the plaque
and you get a plaque
uh when you get a hundred thousand uh
subscriptions
we at the moment
have almost 98 000 subscriptions it's so
close so 2 000
in a world of how many people are in the
world dom
i think is it is do they say about 10
billion at this point
well that's a lot of people we just need
2 000 people to subscribe so get your
friends get subscriptions and then we
can get the plaque we're building
at no expense
or huge expense maybe
an amazing set for me and dom for the
friendship onion and we'd like to put
that plaque up there
um on on the new set
yeah please subscribe to youtube
we're currently not in the studio right
now because obviously i'm away
um
but by the time i get back
hopefully in the next kind of
month or two here we'll be
we might be moving into our new studio
and wouldn't that be lovely to have a
plaque commemorating we could maybe get
a little mini curtain for it as well and
we could open it you know that thing
where you say every every week
and maybe it could have a little theme
tune
brilliant
i'm the black i'm the part i sit there
behind your back can you see me i'm the
black a hundred thousand guys
followers
some of that um all right back together
molly
molly brainerd says yeah i've just moved
across the country and i'm all alone in
an unfamiliar place i've been feeling a
bit homesick but lads watching the
friendship onion makes me feel so much
better thank you for making such a
brilliant and enjoyable show
come on maui thank you molly
thanks molly that's very sweet that's
nice isn't it it's nice
it is nice it is nice thinking things
although i admit i think we talked about
this a while ago that both of us coming
from
britain we always feel a little bit uh
self-conscious about uh people being
complementary towards us right and this
is just the section of the show where
people say nice things about us which is
a bit weird
anyway um well maybe um
yeah
i was going to say maybe we could read
out some of the bad things as well but i
don't think i want to do that i'll just
make me feel sad
um
why don't you read this apple review
billy because i know that you're a big
fan of farting
this includes farting oh that yeah well
this is um
from shin shin
with lots of n's if i had to see how
many i'd say
10 between them shin which says
i broke wind in my chair just like billy
when did that break wind on my shear
dome
i don't remember i mean you have
something
on a chair but not on the podcast on the
podcast
just like billy an excitement once i
discovered that this podcast existed
they should have been doing this years
ago by far the most entertaining and
hilarious podcast out there you're
you're right it's hard to read nice
things about yourself isn't it i find it
easier
if people if people um link us
in the instagram
then we can put that on our instagram
pages and uh i think i like doing that
better i think i like that too but i do
think that's a great compliment when
someone said
i was so excited to hear from you that
it made me lose control of my bowels and
far that's great
billy and dom eat the world
right what are we up to now john
well there's uh
there's a there's a hornet's nest that
we're going to open up here because
we usually eat the world
and we could talk about which is one of
our favorite things it is
not only that but this week
since i'm in another country i suggested
something that we should eat and i
forgot to to get it
that is i mean it's an amateur mistake
though it's an amateur mistake i knew
you know that thing what do you think
you know i think we have something on
the back of your mind that you can't
quite work out i knew that there was
something i had a bunch of different
lists that i was trying to take care of
today and i forgot
to eat the world it i mean
well she'll i'm actually quite hungry so
shall i eat the world quickly
and then you can like you know
say what you want to say about that
give me a second to go and get my jaffa
cakes
okay you've slightly let the cat out of
the bag but that's fine
[Laughter]
right
lovely stuff before you eat the world
and i get jealous and just get sad
watching the world i'm going to give you
a very brief
link of legends update from sean aston
very very similar to elijah's to be
honest just two separate texts
the first one says
just f and a series of u's
nothing else
okay same as elijah what did elijah do
he went
a-g-h exclamation mark
i'm a pirate like a pirate
and then
and then sean astin then wrote just
after that 90 seconds later
i can't get there now how sad
i can't get there
i can't get there now
oh god
does
does sean think we actually go to the
rift
just i think so can you see it
feels quite definite as well doesn't it
as i i can't get there emotionally
to like play games maybe guys
maybe maybe i wonder where there is and
you know how sometimes parents or people
in authority uh positions will say now
as a way of saying this thing is
finished yeah i mean they'll put a line
under it they go now
now
i wonder if he's saying that i can't get
that now
just
get it forget it
all right well you're this is unique and
elijah says
i'm not
welcome
elijah said in a couple of weeks all
right well billy tell us what's going on
this
is a classic
cake stroke biscuit called the jaffa
cake
now when we told john about this he
didn't really know about jaffa cakes so
he suggested
this
which is a different for you just
listening
is it looks like a jaffa cake but it's
made by someone else and it's called a
choco jaffa so i've actually got both of
them here dom
just to see
but i have got the real jaffa cake and
if you don't mind i'm quite hungry so
i'm just going to whiff it down
dive right in
and then we'll get then we'll get into
it
while billy's eating his jaffa k
i'll just talk about it very briefly
at one point
um
i was under the impression that it was
made in ireland and i was like that
can't be right because it's a mcvities
thing which um
generally is in england but it says at
the top here the exact identity
of the world famous edinburgh
invention
the japanese one um
between those who believe it's a cake
and those who reckon it's not a cake now
i don't think it's okay you and i have
our own
opinions about this right it's a it's a
money thing
oh you've separated it lovely
and you're saying it's not a cake
no i think it's a biscuit
masquerading well i think
i think you'll find dom that the british
courts would disagree with you because
it went to court in 1991 if i'm not
mistaken right and they won the battle
to say there was a cake
and therefore they didn't have to pay
tax on it
now what
what defines it as a cake as opposed to
a biscuit because it's biscuit sized and
it's kind of a biscuit vibe right it's
kind of
shaped
and
behaves like a biscuit not a cake so
here's their argument dom
and it's a good one
when a cake gets old
it gets hard
when a biscuit gets old it gets soft
have you had a jaffa cake long enough
that it's got hard on you
like i've done what i do i used to do as
a kid
i've eaten everything except for
the orange center look at that done
it looks like a doubloon yeah i'll tell
you where that is
that is a mouthful of deliciousness now
was it sticky sticky
sticky it's sticky but yet slightly it
could slip off at any point and did
don't drop it
yeah
that's that's great it's almost i would
say it's
slightly bigger than your nose
is it gone
oh orangey goodness jeffrey
that's good if you could look through
the notes i think it does tell us what
the orange bit is made from
excuse me what i was gonna say was
usually when we're eating the world we
we chat a lot
before we eat it you dived right in you
just you've eaten one already it's all
gone
i've been i've eaten too dumb
and i tell you what they're absolutely
this the
delicious they're one of my favorite
biscuit stroke cakes cakes is it well
it's a cake you said i think it's a
biscuit here's one of those comments
that john leaves out there that
is a bit of a nonsense so it doesn't
really make a massive amount of sense
but
we'll read it out anyway just to show
everyone at home what we have to deal
with
with john
he's written michael
is written on their website they wrote
uh and then quote
it contained a simple combination of
sugar and we eat it
what
what is it
the cake and not and it doesn't contain
it contained containers i used to have
it doesn't anymore it contained a simple
combination of sugar and tangerine oil
to form the sealed layer of gem what did
the mystery
the jaffa cake i think they talked about
it it's that gooey stuff that he just
helped but that stuff that is the good
that is this stuff don you know somehow
things just go together well i feel like
the sponge the chocolate and the jelly
thing that you just mentioned that that
contained don't know what it contains
now sugar and tangerine oil
it just all goes together so well if you
don't mind i'm going to try the other
one the fake one
that uh john found on the internet yeah
fine try try to try the charlatan and
let us know any dif any big difference
tell you what i was like done
i'll tell you what it's like
exactly and because of this job that
you're doing do i mean how far in the
future are you in this job maybe you're
not allowed to say but now you have do
you have food processors
half a century into the future but not
like
not a magi mix but you know those food
things where you say to the computer oh
i'll have a jaffa cake and it makes one
it out you don't have one of those and
you're sure do you
no we we don't have one of those but i
could ask should i ask should i make a
demand for them
no you don't need to but i'm gonna let
you know that see these fake jaffa cakes
yeah i feel as if
if the real jaffa cake
is made by the hands of an artist
then that is made by a computer
it tried to make that but it made that
and that
is much better than that
yeah
so that's all the bits are there
and that
yeah but it doesn't taste like that
and when you say that you mean the
original for anyone who's uh just
listening
would it be fair to say that the
original
was painted by
van gogh
but the pretender was painted by picasso
painted by what it just it cut out just
at the moment
the pretender was painted by picasso you
know just kind of all thrown together in
like a random way not really no
no
it would be like
if the original was van gogh
then that was painted
them
by a
monkey okay it's not all all the bets
aren't quite right you know
oh that's a shame
all right but i see the original dom
oh my god the original
well treat yourself to another one while
i'm talking i'll i'll give another one
of these fantastic
uh pieces of information here pull that
instead despite a challenge
by her majesty's customs
to excise
that a jaffa cake is indeed a biscuit
and therefore subject to vat value-added
tax
mcvitty's successfully proved to the
courts that a japan cake is indeed a
cake and it is still
the
t free to this day kind of similar to
what you just said but just word it
slightly differently
but and and delivered magically and i
think that's brilliant
dom they sell over 1
billion every year if you laid them end
to end you create a bridge of jaffas
from london
to sydney
and back again
that's incredible and then this final uh
fact about jaffa cakes before you give
it a score
here's a few great steps for you each
cake takes 18 minutes from start to
finish to make that's quite a lot of
labor time
18 minutes took less than 18 seconds to
eat carry on
it's made made in a factory that covers
10 acres
on a conveyor belt that is over a mile
long
the oven itself is a hundred yards long
the whole process
and they're incredible and this whole
process takes
yields
2 000 jaffa cakes a minute
now scores dumb i'll go fast because you
don't have scores so or can you do
scores from from your memory
for jaffa cakes i'll do memory scores
after yours for sure
right there's memory scores after yours
for yourself
well there's only the two of us here
good point i thought you're gonna go
through the whole skills and then i was
gonna go through the whole schools but i
think you're right i think you're right
me
memory scores taste
eight point
six
eight point six nine aesthetics no this
isn't the packet i remember dom
no it's changed it doesn't it doesn't
come like that it used to come in a way
that they'd all
sort of sit in against each other like
that right in a nice little sort of line
like that i like that i don't like this
as much
so if
if jaffa's now come like this and this
isn't just because i bought it in a
british store in in america if they
actually come like this they've spoiled
the aesthetics
so i can only give it a three
i'm covered in jaffa cakes tom oh gosh
yeah my recollection
from memory was a kind of bluish box
rectangular box quite classy dark
not orange hard cardboard no i don't i
don't like this
i'm gonna give it a
2.7 for aesthetics although the biscuit
itself could you hold that up because it
doesn't seem to have changed too much
the biscuit itself is iconic it's like a
small thin
uh unidentified flying object miniature
size
yeah lovely
so i think yes oh in one i think the
aesthetic of the biscuit is probably
closer to a four
what a good i was good no you're right
john because the aesthetic of the
biscuit with that little ridge
for the oranges absolutely i mean that
is class it's world-class it's it's an
iconic shape
now usefulness i like it with a cup of
tea i don't know about you but i like
the little cup of tea dunking thing
you just double it in there lovely
what could be nicer done
can you think of anything that you could
do with the uh jaffa flat could you
throw you know those toys back in the
day that you used to throw at a window
and then they'd kind of stick on the way
down could you use it as one of them
like a sticky minifigure i mean maybe
like could you use it and like at the
seaside to see if it does that
bounces
skimming
maybe
i'm sure you could do things like
make a cake if you if you didn't have
all this stuff to make a cake i'm sure
if you were a good
chef you could like cut the orange piece
off and make that the top and use the
biscuit as the base
i'm sure you could you could do
something well could i can i ask you
this what would you call
a jaffa cake cake
a jaffa cake cake oh wow yeah
does that
yeah it's like a postmodern cake yeah
it's a cake that knows it's a cake and
it's now commenting on itself
because it doesn't pay v80
do you think some michelin starred
restaurants would call it a
deconstructed jaffa cake
and then would you have to pay that on
it
because it's then
you know two
two negatives make a positive as you'll
remember from from high school math
good point if anyone has any thoughts on
that they just write into the friendship
onion cast media.com that's cassidy k
uh but usefulness what about
what if you had a lesion like a like a
an open wound something like a burn from
the oven or something like that
do we think there's any value in the in
the jaffa cake
diskette
just sticking over and forming a a seal
from the air
like it's
a second skin if you would but an orange
skin orange shape and something orange
scented
i don't see why you wouldn't don't if
you're nothing else in the house didn't
have any super glue then i think the
orange from a jaffa cake would be quite
useful for that
so after that discussion
i'm going to have to give it up there as
um
eight
point
seven eight point seven useful
usefulness
eight i'm gonna say
eight i'm gonna give it a solid eight
score because i would like to try the
next time i i cut my elbow on my knee
attaching the small sticky jaffa
diskette to it and then i'll report back
and let you know how i did
well yeah let us know dom let us know
i've almost done a whole box here where
we've been discussing i'm an abs i'm an
absolute pig when it comes to jaffa cake
storm absolutely i would say
i would say just enjoy it obviously if
there's anyone out there who has grown
up with or become accustomed to a local
delicacy or dish or drink or thing that
billy and i can enjoy on the show and is
easy to get hold of in
you know via environment easy to
navigate online way
let us know at the friendship online at
castmedia.com or you can leave us a
message
at speak by forward slash the friendship
onion
that was very good tom that's very good
and yeah it's always nice we love to
hear from everyone so please do that and
don't forget to subscribe to youtube
because we need to get our plaque
uh for a hundred thousand which
hopefully will happen this week and uh i
don't know if we mentioned we've got
merch did we mention that i think we
mentioned it in passing that there there
is some
merchandise available
just have a think about it should we
finish off should we end the show with a
bang to by working out if something is
funky or not
[Music]
come on dom i love it give us a give us
a funk who's this from dom who's it from
we'll squeeze it in this is from luke
bischoff
and he has he has
offered the song for us
purple disco machine by playbox which
even sounds funky it certainly sounds
funky tom give us a give us it in our
ear holes would you john
[Music]
oh it's a good tune
thanks for that john for letting us hear
that and obviously thanks luke bishop
for uh sending that through for us to
listen to
what did you think tom
i thought funky i thought definitely
funky i'm gonna say
that was um
that was the pointer sisters funky
right nice
i liked it as well i had i mean judging
by this the actual name purple disco
machine it had a little disco thing
going on didn't they dom
enjoy i'm going to say
tom tomtom club funky oh lovely lovely
i like the tomtom club great well i
think that's a wonderful way to finish
the show of course if you guys have any
suggestions for us
for songs that you've grown up with or
that you've just got to know that you
think are really really funky let us
know because billy and i love
um continuing to grow our own playlist
and hopefully you guys as playlists too
yeah we love it when people introduce us
to things that we haven't seen or heard
or read so please send
ideas for us we love that and dom it's
lovely to see you i know that you have
to go and work and you have to go and
travel the globe but it's nice when
you're here but it's lovely to see you
on my computer screen and uh i'll see
you when you're back very soon for one
of your breaks and then head back over
and anyway it's lovely to see you tom
william it's always a pleasure to see
you too i'm sorry that this happened to
be the first ever singular
billion dollar world episode but i think
you absolutely nailed it on your own
i was absolutely i said i'm gonna eat
some more why don't we go on league of
legends while we're both together before
you go to your bed
let's do it all right i will see you
guys next week
don't forget to rate review subscribe to
the friendship onions
[Music]